all right so hello everyone thank you
for joining today's webinar we will be
starting in just a couple of minutes and
in the meantime we are waiting it would
be great if the participants can
introduce themselves in the chat box you
can let us know about your educational
background and your research interests
right we are just waiting for rest of
the participants to join and uh
meanwhile we are waiting it would be
great if partisans can introduce
themselves in the chat box or feel free
to unmute yourself and
let us know about your education
background and your research
foreign
all right so without further delay let's
start with today's webinar so hello
everyone welcome to mix logic before we
get started let me introduce myself I am
Shri gavi krishnamwar research assistant
and biotech and today we have the
introductory webinar for the various
summer training programs that we are
offering which cover topics like big
data by informatics transcriptomics
biomedical data science using Python and
chemical magnets and during this webinar
we will introduce you to the omics logic
learn portal and guide you on how to
navigate it walk you through our
meticulously designed training
curriculums for our various programs and
the various training levels as well as
the associated resources so before we
begin with today's webinar for those of
you who are joining with us for the very
first time let me also take a brief
moment to introduce you to the team
behind the program we are us-based by
informatics company who is working with
multiple academic and Commercial
collaborators to develop ecd use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
and so far the training programs have
been completed by over 24 000
participants from 187 countries in over
300 workshops and our training
coordinators are regularly updating and
customizing the curriculum to suit the
needs of students and researchers
worldwide
and in order to create a clear path of
skill development
we employ the blooms taxonomy levels of
learning in our training programs it
begins with students recalling and
memorizing the facts and progresses to
understanding concepts and applying
knowledge then moves on to analyzing
data and evaluating methods ultimately
students reach the highest level of
learning wherein they can design and
create their own original work
so this is achieved through a
combination of online courses training
modules data analysis tools curated data
sets and interactive mental sessions to
provide theoretical and practical
learning in bioinformatics
to further enrich the training
curriculum we also provide real case
studies that demonstrate the practical
application of bioinformatic methods and
omics data in fields such as medicine
biotechnology Agriculture and even
astrobiology by using the publicly
available data sets these projects allow
students to explore and comprehend
various research questions and Analysis
the omics knowledge of portal also gives
students options for analyzing a given
data set that is code dependent path and
code independent part
so if you are someone interested in
opting the non-food pathway then you
will be given directions to access VT by
info platform for bioinformatic
processing and Analysis of data this
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatics
and different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections we will
be covering about the T by info platform
in Johnson shop right
and after familiarizing themselves with
the T by info platform or pipeline
visualization and Analysis practice
students can then apply their
theoretical knowledge in real projects
they can assess their understanding
through quizzes assignments certificates
of completion and tests and we also
adopt a unique training approach
integrating student learning and
research as discards initially we focus
on building a strong foundation in
bioinformatics and obix data analysis
and as students Banks they hone their
abilities to comprehend how to carry out
literature review replicate
methodologies and so forth and moreover
students are also encouraged to develop
their data exploration skills and
formulate unique meaningful questions
based on their research interests so
here are some of the student case
examples that I want to share with you
very briefly one of our students should
be watching a biomedical science
undergraduate student who worked on a
single underlying reason for development
of rematel nations in multiple sclerosis
patients she was interested in
publishing and went on to publish her
work in immunogenetics which is an Open
Access Journal that focuses on the
genetic research in areas of autoimmune
disorders and another interesting
student publication is that of sapatade
genetic engineering student who was
interested in studying the effect of
malaria vaccine to determine its
efficacy and understand the molecular
mechanisms underlying the protection
that the vaccine provides he also went
on to publish his work in genomics and
informatics which is one of the official
Journal of Korea genome organization
and further you also have the
opportunity to participate in
post-representation competitions and
when exciting cash prizes and twice a
year we conduct women's research
inclusive which is an international
research event that brings together
experts from all around the world
including judges and the student
projects are not just limited to
graduates and documents for instance
Andre a high school student in Mexico
presented his Neuroscience project at
the region 1 international science and
engineering center to which he won the
prime templates
and this program can also be integrated
as a part of the existing University
curriculum for instance our python
courseworks were part of systems
medicine graduate program at Georgetown
University and the training program
ended with students submitting their
projects on various topics such as
infectious diseases metabolic disorders
Neuroscience psychiatric disorders
oncology machine learning and
and these projects can also be showcased
for your higher studies and University
applications such as some of our
students have done like dilera Titan who
got accepted to the Eris Mendes imbrc
program in Marine Biology
got accepted to a Precision medicine and
graduate program at the University of
Manchester and Anusha team who got
accepted to a PhD program in
metagenomics
so faculties and researchers have also
collaborated through our training
programs to publish their research work
and our latest collaboration has been
with a team of researchers at noguchi
Memorial Institute for medical research
at the University of Ghana and They
carried out a computational based study
to understand variants associated with
sulfur toxin resistance in plasmodium
plants
and if you're someone with a passion for
Science and business it is also possible
to pursue an entrepreneurship and
business Innovation track like a team of
industrial researchers from biological
Support Services a biotechnology company
in Nigeria so they developed a
microbiome test kit to improve the
fertility of women in Nigeria and
improve their chances of carrying their
babies to turn and Entrepreneurship
track is not only pursued by researchers
but by students as well
so for instance a group of undergraduate
and postgraduate students worked on
developing an early detection kit for
the identification of Alzheimer's
disease so all of these example projects
and student projects are available on
the omics logic learn portal so let me
walk you through on how you can get
started by signing
so here is the link for creating an
account
I am pasting the link in the chat box so
for those of you who have not created an
account on the portal yet I'll wait for
a couple of seconds for the participants
to sign up and once we have uh sign up
I'll be able to show you the various
Sports work and student projects that
are there on the port
so to create an account you can click on
the create an account button that you
see here and you can enter your name
email ID and password and you can also
log in using any of your social media
handles that includes Google Facebook
Apple account GitHub account or even
Twitter so with that I'll just pause for
a couple of seconds for the participants
to sign up and once you have signed up
please put a yes in the chat box so that
I can walk you through and if you
already have assigned an account on the
portal you can simply put it done in the
chat box so that I get a fair idea
foreign
has already created an account what
about rest of the participants have you
also signed up
along the way if you're having any
technical issues while signing up you
can mention that uh in the chat box as
well and our team members will be able
to help you
all right so I'm just going to start by
signing in but along the way if you want
me to repeat any of the steps please
feel free to do so in the chat box and
I'll be able to guide you so for those
of you who already have an account on
the portal simply enter your existing
email ID and password and click on sign
in
so once you sign in you'll be able to
see the various courses page and you'll
be able to see the courses page where
you'll be able to view the various
courses and example projects that are
there of the portal so if you're
interested to explore all you can do is
go to the course page and here you will
be able to see a search bar that says
looking for a specific course and if
you're someone who's completely new to
the field of bioinformatics then you can
try our introductory courses and by
informatics such as introduction to
bioinformatics course one as well as
first two byton
so we'll be getting to all of them in
just a while
um by one of our team members we'll be
walking you through the various courses
and Associated training programs we
so here is here if you enter any
keywords you'll be able to explore the
courses that we offer and once you
create an account uh do uh update your
account and to be able to do that all
you have to do is head over to the blue
bar on the top and click on welcome back
with your email ID
and here you will be able to see a
profile button so when you click on this
you will be able to edit the various
account features that consist of your
name make sure that your name is in
proper capitalization and that there are
no spelling mistakes because they will
be generated on your certificates as
well and you can also add a profile
image for yourself and a brief bio that
will consist of your education
background and research interests and
finally you can add your social media
handle links in my case I've linked my
LinkedIn account and my own ID
and here you can see the various tabs on
your profile section that consist of
your activity wherein we can monitor
your learning progress and here under
the courses tab to currently display the
course programs that you're making for
the various courses that you have opted
and once you enroll for any of our
training programs you will be able to
see the program uh here and finally
after completing the courseworks with
the required assignments and quizzes
you'll be able to receive the
certificates salary certificate step and
finally here on the blue bar on the top
if you click on the projects tab it will
display the various student projects I
was just talking about in my
presentation so so far if you have any
queries please feel free to post them in
the chat and I'll be able to guide you
and with that I'll toss on the stage to
sonalika who will be explaining more
about the various training programs that
we are currently offering so over to you
thank you so much can you please confirm
up my screen as visit room
yes we can see your screen
thank you so much hello everyone I am
sonalikari I am the bioinformatics
project manager at buying biotech and
today I will be taking you through all
the summer training programs one by one
so this summer we are hosting core
training programs that are specifically
designed for students researchers
professors and clinicians and I will
just take you through each one of these
programs mentioning what the topics are
for each one of them and what other
resources that they're going to cover
so to begin with the goal of the
amishogic programs it is to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research Guided by mentors
and poor example
developing a growing Community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of Citizen science
goal is to enable students clinicians
and faculty of all backgrounds to
develop novel and independent research
using latest technology in life and data
Sciences
during all the summer training programs
that we would be just proposing the
participants could expect a wide range
of valuable features and resources
firstly the program offers online Mentor
guided training and research experience
which ensures that participants receive
personalized guidance and support
throughout the training or The Learning
Journey additionally there are mentor
and subject matter expert videos that
would be shared on the program page that
I'll take you shortly providing further
insights and expertise in the field and
to enhance the Practical aspect of the
program live bioinformatics and
Technical Support would be provided for
the advanced level trainers enabling
participants to receive real-time
assistance with any challenges that they
might encounter
you will also gain the access to the T
bioinfo platform that is a comprehensive
tool that facilitates Hands-On practical
experience in bioinformatics I'll also
take you through the t-bio info platform
shortly in the session and show you how
you can make the most out of the
pipelines to carry out your analysis
moreover the program also integrates
open source Alternatives that
incorporates popular scientific tools
and algorithms that are widely used in
the paint and to reinforce the learning
and assess the progress there are
practice quizzes and graded assignments
that are included as well and upon
successful completion of the program the
participants will receive a
certification recognizing their
achievements and enhancing their
professional credentials
these comprehensive offerings ensure
rich and rewarding experience for
participants that would equip them with
the necessary skills and the knowledge
that is required in the field of
bioinformatics and data science
so whether you are a big no eager to
learn the fundamentals or an experienced
researcher looking to enhance your
skills our training programs caters to
all the levels of expertise and all
these three levels comes with different
access types that I'll just shortly take
you through
now I'll take you through each one of
these programs one by one and to begin
with the first program is Introduction
to bioinformatics so for those who come
from a non-bioinformatics field let us
quickly understand what is
bioinformatics and how do we use it
so bioinformatics is the signs of both
storing lots of complex biological data
and of analyzing it to find new insights
which we use in many different ways and
today's by and today's biomedical
research isn't about publishing one set
of results and hoping other researchers
read it it's about finding patterns in
all the forms of data linking everything
that is out there to provide new
insights that we can only spot if we can
see the bigger picture
so bioinformatics brings us together the
data from lots of experiments in one
place so we can ask those big questions
and find answers
and such data from different sources is
available rather the availability of
such Rich sources of data changes the
nature of biological research itself as
it is rapidly acquiring the character of
data science
so who uses bioinformatics and who is it
for the answer might have been
statistician computer scientists or
Engineers but the truth is that more and
more biologists and clinicians are now
expected to understand and handle their
own data to publish and succeed in basic
and translational research in fact
biology itself is rapidly acquiring the
character of a data science
just mentioned that biology is rapidly
acquiring the character of a data
science billions of data points on genes
proteins and other molecules is compiled
in large files and systematically
studied analyzing this data leads to
more knowledge and understanding about
living organisms which includes human
health biotechnology crops and livestock
so so this training program will give
you an overview of bioinformatics for
students biologists or clinicians and
the influx of data that is associated
with the methodologies and data-driven
research that makes bioinformatics for
Life Sciences as prominent as the
emergence of computers is for the tech
industry
this fiend is based on high throughput
technologies that generates billions of
data points on genes proteins and other
molecules that characterize biological
systems and phenomena these data or
these different data points they are
compiled into the repositories and can
be systematically studied to understand
interrogate and also establish trends
for many applications
now the question is that is such data
available yes and one such repository is
maintained by the national Center for
biotechnology information which has a
collection of peer-reviewed Articles
biological data sets and projects on
various topics
so as you can see in the past several
decades this resource has been growing
exponentially there are over 80 000
publicly available data sets in just one
part of ncpi that is called Geo which
stands for gene expression Omnibus and
such such data repositories contain data
sets on thousands of genes in each
sample with tens or even hundreds of
samples per data set so that's the
amount of data that is present and gu
was just one example there are more such
databases that we need to learn how we
could make the most out of them and
extract the data and make some
meaningful biological insights out of it
so the program that is uh introduction
to bioinformatics is designed to
highlight the role of big Comics data
that is shaping the modern biomedical
Innovation where molecular data is used
for precision Diagnostics Big Data
integration and machine learning that is
transforming personalization of
treatment selection and Innovative
algorithms that allows for unprecedented
capabilities with drug Discovery or
design of large molecules and Drug
repurposing as well
the program covers some of the important
Technologies and its application in
today's world
so the participants will be able to
access these bioinformatics resources
along with expert and mental support to
get help with the learning process that
will help you learn the transformation
of biology to data driven biology
and as a result you will learn about
important bioinformatics Concepts and
applications various applications of
Next Generation sequencing role of data
science of biologists and the industry
challenges that are addressed by Big
Data informatics
next up is transcriptomics for
biomedical data analysis that is an
online training program for students
researchers and clinicians
IT addresses one of the major challenges
in rna-seq analysis that is related to
accurate reproducible and effective
processing of large-scale data sets that
represents gigabytes or even terabytes
of data and such large quantities
prevent many to gain practical Hands-On
feel for rnac
the training program starts with an
introduction to Next Generation
sequencing and then covers the
principles behind it and its
applications
the participants will learn about
sources for transcriptomic data
extraction and gene expression
quantification techniques they would
also be introduced to exploratory data
analysis techniques and downstream data
analysis through differential expression
and biological interpretation
and also they will learn about
functional analysis through pathway
annotation and a range of analytical
tools that could be applied to the to
their own research
and by the end of this beginner level
the participants would have a very good
understanding of the key Concepts and
techniques used in transcriptomic data
analysis
next is the intermediate level that
covers the Advanced Techniques such as
pathway annotation Network visualization
as well as regression analysis you would
also learn about machine learning
techniques for unsupervised and
supervised analysis of rnse data which
includes clustering as well as
classification methods
so that was just a very brief overview
of introduction to bioinformatics and
transcriptomics program
before I jump into the next programs
that includes python or biomedical data
analysis using Python and chem
informatics I'll just shortly take you
through the program pages of
introduction to bioinformatics and
transcriptomics and discuss some of the
elements of these different levels that
I mentioned initially that was uh the
Big Nerd intermediate and the advanced
levels and just look at what resources
are really covered in there
so this is the program page for
introduction to bioinformatics I'll just
share the link in the chat box as well
those who are interested to get started
this summer with an introduction to Big
Data bioinformatics and learn about or
get introduced to these different omics
fields this program is the best fit for
you the link is in the chat you can
explore it as well now I am at the
interface uh where where if a student
has already joined the program they
would see this interface but if you have
not joined the program yet you uh you
won't be able to look at these resources
that are up here so I just wanted to
discuss with you these different
resources that are put together and then
I'll just show you how
enroll for the program
so as mentioned in the training program
you have these three different levels
beginner intermediate and advanced you
can join any of these three levels based
on the uh the type of topics that you
really want to learn about the the depth
that you want to achieve through this
training program and definitely the time
availability
so in the beginner level we would
introduce you to different omics fields
the genomics metagenomics or
transcriptomics and single cell
transcriptomics as well
and in the intermediate level we'll
guide D into genomic data analysis we
learn about multiple sequence alignment
phylogenetic analysis variant calling
and also we'll learn more about
metagenomic data analysis using the data
2 Pipeline and transcriptomic data
analysis from gene expression table to
exploratory data analysis to Downstream
data analysis which includes
differential gene expression and pathway
annotation and in the advanced level you
will learn about these uh different
tools and techniques that could be used
to analyze omics data which includes uh
machine learning using unsupervised and
supervised analysis you will begin with
an introduction to data science first
and then you will dive deep into machine
learning you learn about these different
algorithms or unsupervised and
supervised analysis and also you will
get a taste of cloud computing and get
introduced to programming languages like
R and python that could be used to
analyze or mixed data
so this program introduction to
bioinformatics is a power pack program
with uh with an introduction to all the
important fields in the uh in the free
enviroinformatics that includes omics
data science cloud computing and also RN
python for Big Data analysis
now
resources so on the program page itself
just a second I just close the different
levels first
all right now on the program page itself
you can see these different courses that
are listed out here as a part of this
training program you would get the
access to four different training
programs that you can go through and
learn about omics and tools and
techniques and also introduced to the
programming languages also if you click
on the very first session I'll just give
you an example uh and show you the
resources that are mentioned so for
e-session the topics have been divided
into sub topics and for each one of them
you have a recorded lecture that you
need to go through you will find the
recording of this lecture on the program
page itself it's an embedded video that
you can go through and also you have
these links of associated lessons and
additional reading materials now what
are these Associated lessons they are
hyperlinked if you click on them you
will be redirected to that specific
definition I just showed you the courses
that are present or you have an access
to as a part of a part of this training
program these courses have these lessons
inside it and as a part of each session
you are supposed to go through the
lessons of the sports and complete this
course so if in the beginning we're
introducing YouTube bioinformatics you
need to complete the lessons uh which
introduce you to the field
bioinformatics if it's about genomics
you need to go through this lesson or
transcriptomics or metagenomics and so
on and you have the
Essence present inside each session that
you can click on and you'll be
redirected to complete this specific
lesson
now what is present inside a lesson so
inside a lesson you will find the
context and also you will find images
and videos to supplement your knowledge
and you'll also find some additional
reading material that could be some
educational activities
[Music]
um fun learning activities and also you
will find quizzes and assignments uh to
bring the knowledge that you gain in a
specific lesson once you complete the
lesson you click on the lesson complete
button and proceed
so that was about the associated
coursework lesson that you need to
complete as a part of the session and
also uh you'll find the link to the
additional reading materials inside the
lesson and also on the program page as
well it's given that you need to go
through additional reading material has
been put together for you uh which
refers to the research Publications and
these activities that would be really
helpful to you to go through so we'll
definitely recommend to give a glimpse
to these additional building materials
and if you have time then definitely uh
go through it properly
all right now in some of these sessions
you'll also find the link to the demo
pipelines I'll take you to one of these
demo pipelines in the transcriptomics
program though but I just wanted to
mention here that
um the conceptual part that you have to
take up is present on the Onyx logic
known portal but you also have the T
bioinforce server where all the Hands-On
analysis part has to be done on the
server you have these various sections
for transcriptomic data analysis genomic
data analysis meta genomic data analysis
single cell virology cancer biomachine
learning differential expression G was
phylogenetic analysis a lot of different
useful sections are present here now
here you have these drop down buttons
which will take you to these different
demo pipelines for different analysis so
in the specific session where the mentor
is taking you through a pipeline and is
still an understanding or teaching our
specific pipeline has to be processed
how to take the data clean it or prepare
it and then process the pipeline and how
do you interpret the results
for each lecture where the pipeline
processing has been shown you will find
a link to the demo pipeline that the
mentor has referred to you are supposed
to process this pipeline yourself and
interpret the results
and also you will find the link to the
data or the link to the data set that
has been used in that specific lecture
so you have all the material that is
present on the program page and you can
go through it one by one for each and
every session
so that was about introduction to
bioinformatics now let's quickly go
through the transcriptomics training
program page before we do that if we
have any questions you can please put
them in the chat box feel free to unmute
yourself and take up the question
I just take a pause here for two minutes
if there are any questions you can
please put in the chat box
to also like to know who are from the
participants come from a bioinformatics
field or a non-bioinformatics field and
are interested to get started with an
introduction to bioinformatics
sorry is asking uh about what is systems
biology so systems biology uh helps you
learn about these different network
analysis or pathway analysis uh so you
will learn about not in this program
specifically but if you're interested to
learn about system biology or learn
about how these different systems work
through network of genes and uh Pathways
and how to how do they interact you can
and during the transcriptomics program
I'll just take you through that program
and tell you where these different
concepts are covered and how can we move
from gene expression level to
understanding the network of genes and
how do they interact and which Pathways
do they affect
about the question that you have just
mentioned let's just go through these
programs and then let's get in touch to
have this discussion
for now if you have any questions
related to this training program you can
please put in the chat
and you should also share your email
address with us so that our team can
reach out to you for the question that
you have answered uh shahab is doing his
major in microbiology we have a lot of
people here who come from a different
um
think I'll say a non-bioinformatics
field uh uh so we can take up uh these
technical questions like what is gene
therapy or what is systems biology
definitely uh we can take you through
all of these questions and have you
build the concepts in the program
so if there are no specific program no
specific questions related to program
let's start with the transcriptomics for
biomedical research program here and
I'll just quickly take you through these
three different training programs and
I'll just tell you what all topics uh
would be covered in the beginner
intermediate and the advanced levels and
how can you get started and what are the
resources available
we are Live on YouTube if you want to
refer to the presentation that I just
went through you can definitely refer to
the link
um about publishing I'll just get back
to you on that once I explain the level
types
all right so uh for the transcriptomics
of biomedical research again the same
thing you have these three different
levels bigger intermediate and advanced
you can take up any one of these levels
based on the level of uh the level of
expertise that you want to gain through
this program we'll begin with an
introduction to Next Generation
sequencing technology and we discuss how
the field bioinformatics really emerged
we'll discuss about uh how these
different data types that we get from
these different sequences where are they
stored when are these different
repositories through which you can
access the data if you are a student and
you are not generating your own data set
and you wish to learn how the analysis
has to be done or if you wish to work on
a project there are a lot of data cells
that are publicly available that you can
download and work on so we discuss about
these different sources from where you
can download the data sets and how do
you prepare them how do you clean them
how do you analyze the data and get your
biological insights so once we have a
good good understanding of different uh
sources from where data could be
extracted next we learn how to quantify
gene expression tables from the faster
files or the first few files or the raw
data in general and then how to carry
out expiratory data analysis and
downstream data analysis which includes
differential expression maybe and
pathway analysis or pathway annotation
network analysis all of that this is
covered in the beginner level now in the
beginner level we would go through all
of these concepts with regards to
practical on the T bioinfo server and
how do you process these pipelines and
get your results to maintaining full
biological and science out of it and
also we will learn about some open
source Softails or tools that you can
use to analyze transcriptomic or rnac
data next is intermediate level now in
the intermediate level we will go from
pathway annotation to visualization of
the network of genes and also the
pathways and we'll also learn about
regression and Factor regression
analysis and we'll take up some case
studies to have a good understanding
about these different concepts and also
we learn about machine learning
unsupervised and supervised analysis for
rnac data
so that was about the intermediate level
an advanced level is completely around
the programming languages R and python
so far in the beginner and intermediate
level you will learn about how you could
use the automated pipelines for
analyzing rnse data and also how you can
use open source Tools in softwares to
analyze rnac data but in the advanced
level you will learn about how
programming languages are in Python
could be used for the data analysis what
what are these different libraries and
packages how do you install them how do
you work with them what are these
different types of command lines that
would be used
and to mention the number of sessions in
the beginner level you have six sessions
intimidate you have six sessions and
once you have 12 sessions and you talk
about the time duration it would uh take
you a month to complete the beginner
level a month for the intermediate level
and a month for the advanced level so
that is the time division for all three
different programs
now if you wish to enroll for the
program on the program page itself I'll
share the link of the transcriptomics
page in chat 2. on the program page
itself uh you can find these three
different levels beginner intermediate
and advanced and you can enroll in the
program in the level that you would wish
to
and if you have enrolled in the
beginning level let's say and you wish
to upgrade your level to intermediate or
Advanced you have that option as well as
you can see that uh right now I am
enrolled in the beginner level for this
program I have the freedom to also
upgrade my level to intermediate or
Advanced that's possible on the program
page itself
right now we have uh some early bird
discounts that are up for all these
three different levels so if you are
interested to enroll in the program you
can email us with the level that you're
interested to enroll for and we'll be
able to share with you the coupon code
that you can use to await the discount
so that was about introduction to
bioinformatics and transcriptomics
any questions so far I can see some
questions I'll take a pause for a minute
here and answer the questions first and
then we can learn more about the python
and game informatics program
so babakar is saying that he's a student
in plant biology and reading and needs
to understand gene expression analysis
through bioinformatics tools yes then I
think transcriptomics is the perfect
program for you and in the beginner
level we are explaining uh I just went
through the topics in the beginner level
we have from the third session I believe
yes how G inspiration tables are
Quantified and how the analysis could be
further down that's been given in the
next sessions go to go to this link I'll
recommend and open the different levels
that you have and go through these
topics so that you have a good sense of
what are we covering here and then you
can get started
and also to mention these programs don't
have a specific date of commencement you
can enroll anytime you wish to and get
started these are the summer training
programs that have started you can
enroll anytime and get started
can you please name some of the open
source software used okay so uh when you
talk about databases there are various
databases that we have covered in pcga
paragraphs GDC code how to extract data
from these open source uh the databases
and if you talk about uh the analysis
then not just the d-bio info platform
though you get the pathway enrichment
analysis results as well they have a
differential Express Gene list but we
also refer to
um softwares like react home is there or
incember or enricher or David or h2k web
or Gene Mania as well for network
analysis and pathway analysis so we'll
take you through these uh tools and also
these softwares that you could use for
analysis or biological interpretation of
the differential expressions that you
get and for drug repurposing from RNA
seed we were taken through drug Gene
budget it's there and then you have the
islands that you can refer to or uh the
l-1000 is there so there are various uh
open source softwares that will take you
through for rnac data analysis
uh to understand these different
concepts that you have right now as
questions of curiosity you can
definitely take up the program or it's
not a one-liner answer actually uh that
I can answer you in just one line about
the specific question that you are
answering otherwise I could have
definitely and to mention what is
transcriptomics is the study of
transcripts but that's a very simple
definition if you want to learn more how
the specific our RN receive data is
extracted how it would be analyzed I
would recommend you and vote for the
program and get started that would be
the uh the best way to understand
transcriptomic data analysis
uh suffer for advanced level do we need
Pride uh no supper no Sahar sorry uh no
Sahar you need you don't need any prior
python or our knowledge for uh the
transcriptomic data analysis training
program advanced level I'll just
mentioned why so on the program page you
have in the program course and project
Library the courses that we would cover
in this specific uh program
transcriptomics for biomedical research
now if you click on these uh courses you
would get redirected to the coursework
which includes these lessons that you
need to go through now for R and python
it's not that we jump to the advanced
level of rnac data analysis no we will
take you from the very Basics we'll take
you from from the very basics of how to
install uh python let's see or how to
install our studio as as well and then
how to import data the very basic
functions in R and python will take you
through them first and we'll also go
through the basics or the fundamentals
of the Computing languages first and
then we'll proceed towards exploratory
data analysis and then data
pre-processing and statistical analysis
or differential expression all the type
of analysis specific to rnse so even if
you are a beginner you can get started
uh with the program
okay now let's
have a look at the resources of the
transcriptomics training program
same pilot loads you can put your
questions in the chat
all right so as I already mentioned that
I will be taking you through a demo
Pipeline on the transcriptomics training
program page let us see what a demo
pipeline is and how you could process
data on the T bioinfo server and what
type of results you get that your code
um interpret so on the program page for
the specific program under each session
along with the demo pipeline link and
the data set link you'll also find a
link to the databases and the softwares
that are used so as I had a question I
think it was asked by push that what
type of Open Source softwares you would
use you'll find the link of each and
every database or software that has been
used in the session details itself so
that you can open it or install it and
go through it that is covered in the
session
now let's go through one of these demo
pipelines and see what does it improved
so if you click on the demo pipeline we
would get redirected to the T5 info
server the demo pipeline that you can
process and see what type of results do
you get this is uh quite a big pipeline
to take up as an example for the session
so I'll just take up the demo Pipeline
on differential expression it's pretty
short and simple my idea here is not to
uh really take up the explanation of
each and every tooler algorithm that is
being used here but to show how simple
and easy it is to process a pipeline on
the server you just need to upload the
cleaned data and process the pipeline by
clicking on the specific button that has
an algorithm or a tool and add its
backend and because it's a demo pipeline
you already have the uh the data
uploaded at the backend but when you
process a pipeline you need to select
the specific tool or the algorithm and
set some parameters now what tools to
use what parameters to use what
parameters to set is what you would be
taught in the training program and and
the moment you end the pipeline as it's
a demo pipeline you'll get the results
then and there but if you have your own
data and you process a pipeline it would
uh take few minutes to few hours
depending on the size of the data and
the number of samples
let us see what do we have in the
results that we can look at
now you'll get some results in the
downloads that you can uh download these
files you have in the txt and the PDF
files uh that we will teach you how to
interpret the results from these
different files that you get what do
they mean what type of results do they
include and how do you interpret the
results from them and then you have
these visualization buttons out here
that you uh like when you click on it
let us see what do we have here so we
have a heat map that we can go through
and we have a volcano plot and a
dashboard and square I want to take you
through the plots on the dashboard to
show what type of results do we get I
think I'm facing some issues with my
internet right now that I'm not able to
get along
uh mean select me take you through the
python training program
is there any questions in between for
the transcriptomics program please feel
free to put in the chat
okay so now let's discuss about the
Python program biomedical data science
using python so the demand for a scale
data analysts and scientists who can
derive meaningful insights from the
biomedical data has never been greater
and that's where our online indicator
training program on biomedical data
science using python comes in into play
so in today's rapidly evolving world of
biomedical research the generation of
big data has become the norm and every
day vast amounts of valuable biomedical
data is being produced that holds the
potential to revolutionize our
understanding of diseases and also pave
the way for groundbreaking medical
discoveries
however the sheer volume and complexity
of this data presents a significant
Challenge and that's where data analysis
comes in
so this comprehensive training program
is designed to equip you with the
knowledge and the skills that you need
to excel in the field of biomedical data
science and through a combination of
practical assignments live workshops and
online resources you embark on a
transformative Learning Journey that
will Empower you to unlock the potential
of high robot biomedical data
so in the beginner level of the program
then we get started with uh the program
we will first introduce you to the
different types of comics data that is
present out there and also we'll start
with the basics or the fundamentals of
Python Programming and its applications
to biomedical data analysis you'll start
by understanding the basics such as data
types variables control structures
functions and modules and then you will
dive into data processing and cleaning
using powerful libraries like numpy and
pandas
and once you are armed with these skills
you will move on to expiratory data
analysis paging visualization libraries
like matplotlib and c bond to uncover
the patterns and the relationships that
are hidden within your data recently you
will also gain an understanding of
dimensionality reduction techniques and
machine learning using libraries like
scikitron
and as you progress to the intermediate
level you will deepen your understanding
of clustering and also Advanced machine
learning techniques that are
specifically tailored for biomedical
data analysis you will explore
clustering techniques like canines
practical clusterings and spectral
clustering using python clustering
packages like scikit and sci-fi and also
learn model validation techniques and
evaluation metrics for supervised
machine learning models and they're
going to Advanced machine learning
Technologies like decision tree random
Forest svm LDA and umap and apply them
to real world biomedical data sets
so that was a very brief overview of the
biomedical data science using python
training program I'll shortly take you
through the program page and show you
what resources are covered for each and
every uh session of the program
the last uh program that we have up for
the summer is scam informatics for
biomedical drug Discovery and this
program has been put together in the
quest of groundbreaking biomedical drug
discoveries and as this team has emerged
as a powerful Catalyst for innovation
so over these years the evolution of
Technologies in cheminformatics has
revolutionized the drug Discovery
landscape and by harnessing the power of
computational tools and data analysis
researchers can now navigate complex
chemical and protein databases with
unprecedented speed and accuracy
and this training program is designed to
address these challenges that are
associated with the understanding
modeling screening and then applying
cheminformatics strategies to improve
drug Discovery results throughout the
training program you will gain practical
skills that form the foundation of
cheminformatics so from exploring
chemical and protein databases to
predicting protein structures you will
develop a solid understanding of the
tools and the methods as well that are
used in drug discovery
once you have gained this knowledge next
you would also learn or gain in science
into the chemical structures and their
representation you will learn about the
basics of drug design and optimization
and learn how to explore the exciting
intersection of machine learning
algorithms and can informatics data
analysis as well and as you progress
further your knowledge will expand
building upon a strong foundation in
molecular biology
bioinformatics and chem informatics and
here you will explore the latest
advancements in the field such as Alpha
food and virtual screening for hit
identification
now through these 12 immersive sessions
uh that you will come that you will
cover until the intermediate level you
would learn about virtual chemical
screening techniques which includes both
vegan and structure based approaches and
you will also gain a hands-on experience
with uh
softwares like I will slab and different
protein databases
moreover you will also discover the
transformative potential of AI in
molecular drug Discovery and its
applications in healthcare and I got a
question in the chat about the
publication or a research project so in
the advanced level of this training
program you will stand a chance to
propose a research question to your
meter that you could work upon and
ultimately work on a research project
with your mentor and have a publication
out of it so that was a brief overview
of the program biomedical data science
using Python and can informatics now I
would like to take you through the
program page of biomedical data science
using python it just flows up the pages
that we have covered
all right
so I'll just share the link in the chat
yes you can definitely work on NGS data
analysis and that is what is being
covered in the transcriptomic data
analysis training program and
introduction to bioin informatics
program as well you introduced to the
film but if you want to gain an
expertise you can enroll in the
transcriptomics training program and
learn how you can do that
so I'll share the link in the chat for
the python training program
now let us look at the components of the
program so you have these three
different levels beginner intermediate
and advanced and I mentioned what all
topics you would be going through so in
the beginner level you would be
introduced
uh yes goodness we do have scholarships
available for the programs I'll just
take you through it at the registration
step so at the beginner level we will
introduce you to the omics data analysis
different fields of comics genomics
genomic data transcriptomic data
metagenomic data what it looks like so
that uh you have a sense of the type of
data that you have to deal with when you
go through each one of these sessions
where you are analyzing the data and
interpreting biological insights out of
it you'll learn you'll get started with
the basics or the fundamentals of python
and then you will learn how to explore
data get your basic statistics and then
visualize data using different
techniques and you would be introduced
to machine learning in the intermediate
level you would be you'll dive deep into
all of these different machine learning
uh libraries and packages that you can
work with for a building a predictive
model and at the advanced level we'll
take you through some advanced based on
video selection generalized linear
regression model and also you will learn
about network analysis and the learning
and we would take up some case studies
here for different types of data towards
them where we learn how transcriptomic
data could be worked with uh using
python or single cell data analysis or
genomic and metagenomic studies and
towards the end you have a Capstone
project that you would be working on now
if you noticed in the python training
program you have these collab links that
are given for each and every session so
I like to take you through these collabs
so along the session video and the
associated lesson and the additional
material you'll also find a collabular
that you have to go through and practice
enough
meanwhile the collab loads I'll just
open the coursework associated
coursework as well so for this program
you are supposed to go through bioinfo
in Python uh one and and course 2. in
every program you might have noticed
that these two programs are there the
first program introduces you to
different omics data types and the
second program by its and molecules
introduces you to different resource
specialization tracks which includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine agriculture Neuroscience
metabolic disorders so that you know how
different armies data could be worked
upon or analyzed in different resource
specialization graphs so this is to this
is for you to develop a basic or a
fundamental understanding of earnings
data and its applications in different
research tracks and they gain these
specialization uh in different uh types
of courses that you pick as a part of
the program
so now what is inside the python course
tool
inside python course 2 you'll find these
different lessons and
it's not that if you are a big note you
need to First Complete python course one
and only then jump to python course to
python course 2 also starts with a basic
or a beginner level that you can get
started with and it will slowly take you
to an intermediate and an advanced level
you will first learn how to import
different types of data and then
can your expiration analysis visualize
data using different visualization
techniques through box plots heat Maps
scatter plot and then you will learn how
to perform descriptive statistics on it
and then also performed image money
reduction through different methods and
you will learn about different machine
learning supervising unsupervised
clustering and classification algorithms
deep learning network analysis and that
is all that you have for the python
portion now if I open up one of the
courseworks it's pretty interesting to
see that inside the lesson you have the
concept explained first you have the
concept explained and then you have the
code block you have the explanation for
each and every core block before that
you also have the uh description of each
and every package or library that has
been used and you are supposed to learn
about that specific Library first learn
about the code block understand that
code block
and once you have a good understanding
about the same then you can practice the
same on the Google collab so we uh share
these Google collabs we are there on the
program page you are supposed to uh
create a copy of this Google collab and
practice it along as you go through each
and every session and we have the access
to your collabs and if you have any
doubt or any error that comes up in your
collab you can share the link with us
and we can help you Rectify your error
that is why we recommend working on
collab so that we can help you uh
Rectify your errors
so that was about the resources for the
python training program now let us see
what do we have for the game informatics
training program I'll share the link in
the chat box if there is any question
you can please put in the chat before I
uh go to the chem informatics program I
would like to answer goodness uh
question on the scholarship that is
available for the programs yes we do
have scholarships available for the
program for all three different levels
that I've explained beginner
intermediate and advanced you have
different scholarships available you can
email us on support
omnislogic.com and we can help you with
the specific type of scholarship that
you can take up you need to mention what
type of level you want to enroll for and
then we can help you with the code
all right now for chem informatics
training program
for came informatics training program
you have the levels here and you have
the uh specific types of uh sessions and
the topics that we would be covering
here now what different you will find
here along the session videos and uh
Associated lesson any additional
material is the link to the data file so
cheminformatics for biomedical drug
Discovery program includes these
Hands-On sessions every session is
almost a Hands-On session in the
beginning of the session you have some
Concepts explained first and then you
have a Hands-On practical towards the uh
other half of the session so you have
the link of the data file that the
mentor has referred to in the session
lecture and also you have the link to
the database or tool or software that
has been used here so that you can
um
download it or go through it and then
also complete your practical Hands-On
alongside
and you can go through these different
types of topics that are covered at the
beginner intermediate and advanced steps
I won't be going in too much depth there
as we are short of time right now and I
just take you through the resources that
we will be covering here we have the
structural biology and chem informatics
coursework
as a part of this training program that
you need to cover and for uh structural
bio and chem informatics we have covered
almost a lot of tools and softwares that
could be used from uh Target structure
prediction to docking we have covered
the explanation and how to explore these
protein structures through different
chemical and protein databases and you
we have covered each and every topic
from the very Basics to an advanced
level so even if you don't have any
background in structural priority and
informatics you can get started with the
program
and in the program we also have a few
lessons you can see that there is one
lesson in rn2 lesson uh sorry one lesson
in Python and two lessons in R so you
can go through the basics first if you
are a novice and then you can go through
these Python and R code blocks to
understand how alpha root
okay
so that was about cheminformatics and
structural biology coursework
are there any questions you can please
put them in the chat box
now the question is how do you enroll
for the program so if you wish to enroll
for the program we have shared the link
in the chat box we you'll also find the
links of the training programs in your
email address if you scroll down to on
the program page you'll find these three
different levels ignore intimidate and
Advance you can reach out to us for the
scholarship code on the coupon code and
we'll share it with you once you have
applied these codes uh here you will get
a scholarship to endure for the program
and you simply need to click on the buy
now button and that will take you to the
checkout page through which you can
enroll if you face any problem or any
technical issue with the payment
gateways you can reach out to Mr SRI
datta on devadurate finder bio and he
will be able to assist you with the same
so that was how you can enroll for the
program
uh please share the specific program
that you wish to enroll in which level
do you want to enroll for and our team
will share with you the scholarship
details and the coupon codes
you can email uh shubham on support at
amazon.com and he will assist you with
the same
all right so I'll take a pause now are
there any questions if anyone has any
questions feel free to put in the chat
or you can unmute yourself as well
if there are no questions I think we are
good to end today's session
for joining today and you can reach out
to us our email address has been shared
in the chat and we would be there to
assist
thank you have a nice day
thank you so much everyone have a great
day bye